hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
a lo largo de la historia ha habido
gente muy brillante ha habido gente que
con una idea un pensamiento ha logrado
cambiar la forma de ver el mundo de
muchas personas
mis ejemplos podrían ser leonardo
davinci con su tornillo aéreo que
sabemos que es el precursor de lo que
conocemos hoy en día como el helicóptero
o alexander von humboldt teorizando en
cosmos como todo está conectado
y este es mi punto de partida para poder
decir que hay gente fuera de su tiempo
gente adelantada
no es maravilloso como hay gente que en
vez de ver una sociedad llena de tabúes
llena de barreras de pensamiento logran
ver una oportunidad para hacer cambiar
la forma de pensar del mundo
imaginemos imaginémonos un mundo en el
que todos nosotros compartíamos las
ideas más absurdas que se nos ocurran no
sé podríamos tener coches voladores o
máquinas para alterar el clima
y esto se oye muy bonito pero qué es lo
que pasa cuando creemos haber tenido una
idea excelente una idea trascendente
vaya
por lo general nos quedamos callados
quien de aquí ha visto alguna vez star
wars
pues yo lo personal me considero un fan
a mí desde chiquito me maravillaba a ver
este mundo en el que los duelos de
sables de luz eran posibles en un mundo
en el que los viajes intergalácticos
eran reales me encantaba ver este mundo
porque todo lo que uno cree que es
imposible ahora resulta que es posible
y yo tiene un grupo de amigos con los
que hablaba sobre esto con los que
hablaba sobre star wars
y un día se nos ocurrió por qué no
hacemos nuestro propio sable de luz
dijimos bueno está fácil no necesitamos
un láser para con este punto es un
pizarrón
necesitamos metal así para que sea
bonito para que esté chulo
necesitamos tales espejos o lentes
y empezamos a hacer dibujos empezamos a
imaginarnos cómo podría ser este sable
de luz
pero llega un momento en el que mi
cabeza de nieve primaria escucho esta
voz que me dice
como crees que vas a lograr hacer eso
como crees que eso es posible como crees
que hace ser un sable de luz y el
problema saben cuál fue decidí creerle a
mi cabeza hoy en día ya existen láseres
muy potentes
y claro ahorita yo lo veo en
retrospectiva y dios no pues ni idea ni
tan lo que estaba usando estaba tan
cuidado como yo pensaba
y este pensamiento limitante no siempre
tiene que venir de uno mismo puede ser
de la sociedad o no se puede ser una
persona en específico
me gusta mucho usar en este momento el
ejemplo de alexander von humboldt
cuando la madre de humboldt se enteró de
que su hijo quería ir a américa para
catalogar plantas y animales
no se lo podía creer y me gusta
imaginarme esta escena más o menos así
yo me imagino que en este momento la
madre de humboldt le dijo algo así
mira
yo me muero ahorita
y tú te vas a américa
te prometo que yo muerta voy déjalo de
las patas
imagínense que le hubiera hecho caso a
su madre y hubiera decidido quedar en
prusia no sé de tal vez no tendríamos
una teoría de evolución o tal vez no
tendríamos conciencia sobre lo que
hacemos al deforestar que claro no estoy
diciendo que tengamos conciencia no pero
por lo menos alguna de sus ideas todavía
tenemos en la actualidad
y todo esto no lo tendríamos solamente
por una idea reprimida porque se le dijo
hay un bot lo que estaba bien hacer y se
le dijo lo que estaba mal hacer
se le dijo lo que era posible y también
se le dijo lo que era imposible
lo que es imposible y lo que es posible
siempre todo lo que hoy consideramos
posible alguna vez tuvo que ser
considerado un posible
no sé me gusta el ejemplo de leonardo da
vinci con el tornillo aéreo que mencioné
ya previamente
hoy sabemos que por esta idea de
leonardo davinci tenemos helicópteros
quien esté no renacimiento se hubiera
imaginado que tendríamos las máquinas
voladoras pues nadie bueno leonardo da
vinci no claro
y fue algo imposible que se convirtió
posible y no nos vayamos tan lejos
tampoco
podemos agarrar otro ejemplo no sé de
los eclipses antes se creía que los
eclipses eran causados por una batalla
entre el sol y la luna o que el sol era
devorado por un ser místico y pues si
hubo alguien que dijo
pero a ver qué tal que la luna pasa
frente al sol y que anda tierra vemos la
sombra
y si seguramente hubo que le dijo no me
están dando como la sombra
eclipse
sí
y al final resultó que no solamente ese
pensamiento que era considerado
imposible
es entonces posible no solamente eso
también resultó que es la realidad es
justamente como pasa
en la actualidad tenemos las cosas mucho
más fáciles hoy en día si tú tienes un
interés y tú tienes una intriga basta
con
y tienes listas y listas y listas de
enlaces a los que te puedes meter para
saciar tu hombre de tu hambre de
conocimiento para saciar tu inquietud
también tenemos muchas menos barreras de
pensamiento que antes y digo menos
porque claro no se puede decir que hay
sí ahora ya no tenemos barras de
pensamiento yo creo que si yo les dije
ahorita ustedes yo quiero estudiar
música tales para que haya gente que me
diga guau qué padre que padre que haya
gente todavía que se interese por las
artes no que padre que haya gente que le
guste la música pero tal es por acá
puede haber gente que me diga ahí sí
música que padre y de que vas a vivir
más pero algo les puedo asegurar estamos
en un mejor lugar que hace 200 años al
respecto
y otro punto es la libertad hoy en día
tenemos libertad y podemos hablar de
libertad de expresión
hoy en día si tú tienes una idea si tú
quieres decir algo no te puedo decir que
no puedes decirlo nadie te puede
censurar
y también podemos hablar de la libertad
de vivir la vida como tú quieras en este
punto quiero mencionar una frase que se
nos adjudica sobre todo a los jóvenes y
es la de yolo
jolie ones vive solo una vez
este concepto se me hace muy interesante
porque es verdad solo vimos una vez no
y uno tiene que aprovechar su vida para
lo que uno quiera y hoy en la actualidad
ya tampoco nadie te va a decir cómo
vengo a ver no te vayas américa acá a
catalogar plantas o animales o ya tú
tienes la decisión sobre lo que vas a
hacer
y con esto lo que yo quiero llegar es
que ya no se necesita en la actualidad
ser una persona extraordinaria ya no se
necesita haber nacido en cuna de oro ni
tener todo el dinero del mundo y claro
mucho menos haber estudiado todos los
libros que existan
en la actualidad a veces solamente
necesitamos callar estamos que te dice
no no puedes como crees es imposible
tal vez algún ustedes aquí tengo una
inquietud que ahorita considera loca o
absurda no sé no estoy diciendo que
quieran hacer sables de luz no pero
alguna inquietud todos tenemos alguna
idea algún pensamiento
y tal vez aunque ustedes piensen que es
muy loco puede que en algunos años
trascienda tal vez en el futuro alguien
diga que quiere cambiar el clima
y tal vez algún día esa idea sea básica
para la sociedad tal vez esa idea algún
día los haga trascender como gente fuera
del tiempo en el que crecieron
[Aplausos]